bonsoir bref m demain c'est donc le
début du ramadan le gouvernement
tunisien pris des mesures
exceptionnelles pour l'occasion comment
vont s'organiser les tunisiens pour ce
mois de jeunes en pleine pandémie
effectivement c'est un mois assez
spécial que les tunisiens s'apprêtent à
vivre un mois du ramadan qui est connu
dans le monde entier dans le monde
musulman surtout comme un mois où les
familles se réunissent énormément où les
gens ont l'habitude de sortir et de se
réunir notamment à la mosquée après la
rupture du jeûne cette année ça va être
différent un cas de figure complètement
exceptionnels soit en tunisie ou alors
dans le reste du monde
le gouvernement a déjà pris ces
dispositions il a annoncé que le
couvre-feu passerait de 18 heures à 20
heures pour permettre aux tunisiens de
pouvoir et se retrouver et puis pouvoir
profiter de ce mois sans aucune pression
le confinement en restait tant qu'à lui
toujours d'actualité le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'à partir du 3 mai il y aurait
un techniquement partiel par région et
par secteur d'activité on a pu observer
depuis hier que les rues étaient
beaucoup plus bondées que d'habitude
les marchés étaient bondées que
d'habitude et tunisiens sont de plus en
plus nombreux à vouloir se proposait
affaires de circuler à faire des
provisions pardon pour ce mois du
ramadan mais quelques consignes sont
respectées par une amende au gouvernorat
et de mairie notamment à distance
sociale des préventions de port du
masque aux leurres l'utilisation de gels
hydroalcooliques j'avais le gouvernement
craint quand même que la population soit
amené et puis et tenter de sortir un peu
plus en ce mois de juin en avant et que
les noms de sécurité ne sont pas
respectées
et puis gouvernement a également annoncé
qu'une aide financière supplémentaire
sera allouée aux familles les plus
démunies pour pouvoir tenir tout seul
mois du ramadan on voit là une situation
exceptionnelle pour les tunisiens pour
les musulmans dans le reste de la
planète
donc il va y avoir il va falloir
s'adapter cette année pour ce ramadan et
qui bien sûr ne pas oublier qu'on est
encore en même temps des demies du
comité 19 et surtout faire attention
merci bassem chez billets en direct de
tunisie